[Musique]
suivez la lumière
comment vous sentez-vous Daniel salut et nous donner
mahlia bien l'enfer de le faire est de la
pure majesté Je ne sais pas de quoi vous
parlez en
quelque sorte me fait peur un grand vieux
voyant que rien sans classe ne commencera
dans  153 minutes beaucoup une heure avant de
prendre le purgatif et s'il vous plaît assurez-vous
de consommer le liquide requis et de les
mordre en retour Je voulais juste dire bonjour
avant de sortir de l'antenne en créant vraiment
bien Je commence on va
avoir un verre de plus  avant de gagner le
sommeil cryo qui va mener au
toast de la tour a dit à n'importe quelle machine DSL
aujourd'hui bon capitaine assurez-vous que votre propre
base oh ouais tu me tues
bien comme une chose comme ce lapin se
sent mieux
est-il parti ouais d'accord
pourquoi je  sais que tu peux m'entendre de
Lagos, pourquoi saurais-tu que j'ai entendu parler de
ces insectes fous juste une dernière
entreprise d'oniel ils ressemblent à des cafards de la
taille d'une dope géante d'
accord Bernard arrête d'essayer de manger oh
allez c'est à peine de la nourriture mais j'aime
rire nerveux  Oui, tous les deux, je suis dans cette
grand-mère en haut, nos nachos vont vous manquer.
avoir une bombe excitée ouais Jake m'a demandé
de dire quelque chose d'accord s'il
vous plaît vous avez tous tant sacrifié pour être ici
pour faire partie de cette toute première
mission de colonisation à grande échelle à venir
aussi loin dans notre galaxie, faisant de l'histoire
tout le monde sur elle  elle est vraiment
reconnaissante Lauren pour ton travail acharné ton
courage Je veux juste dire que je ne pourrais pas
choisir un meilleur groupe de connards pour me faire
abandonner sur une planète lointaine avec donc je
vais commenter
[Musique]
Tu es sûr de ce capitaine, qu'est-
ce que tu veux dire par là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]